[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء نبداوها بابرز العناوين
مع المفاجات الاسيويه في المونديال
العربيه
وتوقعاتهم للمنتخب الفائز
اسبانيا
فرنسا
الكرديه شمال سوريا وتقصف منشاه للغاز في
الحسكه
النظام الايراني يرسل قوات حربيه لقمع
الاحتجاجات في المدن الكرديه ودعوات
لاضراب عامه لمواجهه القمر
بعد هجره المهندسين تويتر تواجه هجره
المعلنين وماسك يحمل جماعات حقوق المدنيه
مسؤوليه الخسائر
[موسيقى]
بعد انتصار السعوديه على الارجنتين جاءت
اليابان لتفجر المفاجاه الثانيه بانتصارها
على الماكينات الالمانيه رغم كافه
التوقعات كانت تصب في مصلحه المنتخب
الالماني المغرب وكرواتيا انهيار اللقاء
بالتعادل فيما لم تقدم كوستاريكا اي مستوى
يوقف مسيره المتدور الاسباني فخسرت بسبعه
اهداف مقابل لا شيء منذ قليل
ومعتزايد الحماس الموندياليه استطلعت
العربيه اراء الجماهير في الدوحه
وتوقعاتهم لمن سيحسم اللقب
بطل كاس العالم
البرازيل
ان شاء الله المانيا
السعوديه ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
تنقل لنا الاجواء الاحتفاليه حيث تتواجد
وتاثير
الجماهير العربيه تحديدا في هذا المونديال
يعني ان يقام هذا المونديال على ارض عربيه
وبحضور كبير لجماهير عربيه كيف اثر ذلك
على الاجواء والنتائج
لا نسمعك عبد المحسن
ليس هنالك سوسن وعوده الاتصال
اذا المشاهدين بعد الفوز التاريخي للمنتخب
السعودي على نظيره الارجنتيني ضمن كاس
العالم بقطر بثنائيه لواحد افتتحت ابرز
الصحف العالميه اعدادها بالحديث عن
النتيجه معبره عن اعجابها باداء الاخضر
السعودي امام رفاق الاسطوره يونيون ميسي
في المونديال ما زال حديث الكل ويثير ردود
الافعال
ثنائيه امام منتخب المرشح لاحراز اللقب
جعلت الصحافه العالميه تفتح قاموس المدح
وتستعمل كلماته للتعبير عن اداء ابهر
الجميع امام رفاق صاحب الكره الذهبيه
السبع انها اللدغه العربيه هكذا عنوانه
صحيفه البريطانيه صدر صفحتها الاولى
وتابعت بالقول ميسي يفشل في تحقيق الفوز
ضد السعوديه في احدى مفاجات كاس العالم
حيث خسرت الارجنتين لاول مره في اخر ثلاث
سنوات اما صحيفه الجارديانا البريطانيه
فعلقت الدوسري بطل صدمه زلزال في
المونديال وتبعت السعوديه تصدم الارجنتين
بهدفين متتاليين وتلحق بها الهزيمه صحيفه
ماركا الاسبانيه قنبله ناريه تاريخيه في
وجه الارجنتين فيما كتبت صحيفه موندو
ديبورتيفو الاسباني ايضا ضربه قويه
للارجنتين امام السعوديه
اما صحيفه انت البرازيليه فقد وضع تعليقا
طريفا على النتيجه بقولها شكرا للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه جعلتم صباحنا جميلا في
البرازيل شكرا لكم من 200 مليون برازيلي
مباراه ستبقى راسخه في اذان المشجعين
السعوديين والعرب وفي كل انحاء العالم بعد
ان كتب الاخضر السعودي بدايته في
المونديال بمداد من ذهب العربيه
الصبر
خالده اخضر
ومن جديد ينضم الينا من الدوحه نتمنى ان
يكون يسمعني عبد المحسن الحربي اهلا بك من
جديد عبد المحسن يعني كنت سالتك عن تاثير
الجماهير العربيه
في هذا المونديال تحديدا
[موسيقى]
يوم امس حول ملعب لوسيل قبل بدايه مباراه
المنتخب السعودي ضد الارجنتين سالتهم قلت
بان العدد جماهيري السعودي كبير وكاننا في
الرياض هل سيؤثر ذلك على اداء المنتخب
السعودي بداخل الملعب طبعا كانت همم
الطموحات بان يتلقى السعوديه اقل عدد ممكن
من الاهداف لكن ذلك التاثير همم اصبح
واضحا جدا على ارضيه الملعب بعد اداء
تاريخي للمنتخب السعودي في ملعب لوسيل
والتغلب على الارجنتين في تاريخ او في
مباراه تاريخيه يوم الامس بعد ذلك كل
المنتخبات العربيه شاهدنا عدد كبير جدا من
الجماهير لمختلف الدول العربيه المشاركه
اما المغرب وتونس او حتى السعوديه وحتى
الدوله المستضيفه قطر جماهير عربيه في كل
مكان توازي المنتخب منتخباتها بالاضافه
الى ذلك حضيه المنتخبات العربيه المشاركه
هنا همم
عرفت من كافه الجنسيات العربيه المتواجده
في همم قطر همم
بفعل او تواجد هذا المونديال في قطر ساحل
من وجود عدد كبير جدا من الجاليات العربيه
سواء كان موجوده في قطر او حتى القادمه
خصيصا لهذا المونديال فبالتالي اصبحت همم
المنتخبات العربيه تحظى بدعم جماهيري عربي
كبير حتى الان يؤثر ايجابيا على مستوى همم
اداء للمنتخبات العربيه سواء كان السعوديه
او غيره من
المنتخبات خلافا لذلك همم قبل قليل انتهت
مباراه المنتخب الاسباني
بكوستاريكا بنتيجه تاريخيه ايضا سبعه سبعه
صفر لكل خلق من هذه المنتخب التي سبق لها
بطوله بعد الاداء تاريخي للسعوديه اليوم
ايضا المستوى الكبير الذي قدمته اليابان
ضد المانيا واطاحت بها فبال اصبح هناك قلق
من المنتخبات الاقل حظوظا اعاده من
المنتخبات التي تملك تاريخ طويل في هذه
البطوله اوروبا همم اصبح حديث الصحافه
الدوليه يقولون ما الذي يحدث في قطر بعد
هذه النتائج التاريخيه والتغيرات الكبيره
في النتائج من قبل سواء كان المنتخب
الياباني ضد المانيا وحتى السعوديه ضد
الارجنتين همم في هذه المباريات التاريخيه
راويه
عبد المحسن الحربي
[موسيقى]
افاده مراسل العربيه بان طائره مسيره
تركيه استهدفت محطه الكهرباء الرئيسيه في
مدينه القامشلي شمال شرق سوريا والحقت
اضرار في المحطه ما تسبب من قطاع الكهرباء
عن مناطق واسعه من المدينه التي تعتبر
عاصمه للاداره الذاتيه المعلنه من قبل
الاكراد
قبل ذلك جددت انقره تهديداتها باجتياح بري
ضد الاكراد التي تعتبرهم فصيلا ارهابيا
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد ان
تركيا سترشون قريبا عمليه في سوريا ضد
المقاتلين الاكراد التصعيد التركي تمثل
اليوم باستهدافي مسيره تركيه لاهم منشاه
غاز قرب مدينه بريك بريك ادى الى وقوع
اصابات وباكثر من 20 قذيفه صاروخيه قصفت
القوات التركيه مناطق انتشار القوات
الكرديه شمالي حلب من دون معلومات عن
خسائر بشريه وفق المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان كان المرصد اشار الى سقوط سبعه
صواريخ بالقرب من معبر باب السلامه على
الحدود السوريه التركيه في ريف اعزاز شمال
حلب كما سقطت عده صواريخ داخل الاراضي
التركيه في المقابل سقطت صواريخ قربه
مخيمات للنازحين تحديدا قرب معبر باب
السلامه مصدرها القوات قوات النظام
[موسيقى]
تمسكوا انقره باطلاق عمليه عسكريه ضد
الوحدات الكرديه في سوريا دفع موسكو الى
الاعلان عن اجتماع مرتقب في الاستانه بين
روسيا وتركيا وايران بشان سوريا هنا نتحدث
عن مصالحه او ربما تسويه تحاول روسيا
العمل عليها منذ سنوات بين حليفتها دمشق
وانقره التي ساندت المعارضه السوريه في
الحرب الاهليه الاسابيع الاخيره شهدت
اشارات صغيره اوليه على احراز تقدم طفيف
لكن هذا التقدم تعرض للتهديد بعد التوترات
التي اندلعت نهايه الاسبوع بين تركيا
واكراد سوريا الذين يسيطرون على جزء كبير
من شمال
تركيا ضربات جويه على مواقع كرديه في
سوريا والعراق واصابت هذه الضربات مواقع
للجيش السوري ادت الى عدد من القتل
والجرحى سوريا تخشى من ان تنفذ تركيا
تهديداتها نقوم بتوغل بري جديد في البلاد
الامر الذي تعهدت ان تتصدى له القوات
الكرديه المدعومه من الولايات المتحده
وتتفق تركيا مع النظام السوري في عدائهما
للاكراد السوريين لكن التشارك في الخصومه
لم يكن كافيا حتى الان للتغلب على اسباب
الخلاف الاخرى حيث تدين دمشق سيطره انقره
على مساحات شاسعه من شمال سوريا على طول
الحدود المشتركه منذ العام 2016
وبحسب الخبراء سوريا تعتبر ما حدث عدوان
وهذا يؤثر على اي وصفات ايرانيه او روسيه
قد تفتح الابواب المغلقه بين انقره ودمشق
اذا وجوده تركيا داخل سوريا يمثل عاقبه
رئيسيه امام المصالحه بعد دمشق
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من مدينه البريطانيه رامي عبد
الرحمن مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
اهلا بك سيد رامي يعني اذا اردنا الحديث
عن هذا اجتياح البري التركي ان حصل ما هي
الفصائل
التي يمكن لتركيا ان تستخدمها داخل سوريا
نتحدث هنا عن توزعاتهم وايضا عن الجوزيه
جوزيه تلك الفصائل
نعم مساء الخير نبدا من دمشق حقيقه الامر
حتى ان هل هناك اجابه حقيقيه
للعدوان التركي المحتمل على الاراضي
السوريه
وحتى لو قتلها اكثر من 20 جندي بقوات
النظام فيها استهدافات تركيه ما هي
الفصائل هي فصائل ما يسمى بالجيش الوطني
التي ترفع الرايه التركيه الى جانب رائد
علم الثوره السوريه همم هم يقاتلون
وقاتلوا الى جانب اردوغان قاتلوا باوامر
حكومه التركيه لرواتبهم من الحكومه
التركيه تدفع هذه الرواتب بالليره التركيه
لهم هذه الفصائل هي جاهزه لتعتبر باوامر
حكومه التركيه للمشاركه بقتل ابناء الشعب
السوري مثل ما شاركت في قتل ابناء الشعب
الديبي وقتل ابناء الشعب الارمني عندما
تحول الى مرتزقه في هذه المناطق هذه
الفصائل التي ستدفع بها تركيا الى الواجهه
لقتال ابناء الشعب السوري في شمال وشمال
الشرق سوريا ولكن نقول
في اعترضت اعتمد الحكومه التركيه بشكل
اساسي على هذه الفصائل من اجل الغزو
كوباني غزو منبج غزو مناطق اخرى تسيطر
عليها هواء سوريا الديمقراطيه او القوات
الكرديه وهل هناك ضوء اخضر روسي هذه المره
من اجل هذه العمليه لغزو الشمال السوري
نعم بشكل اعضاء بشكل القطري ان كان هناك
عمليه عسكريه مرتبه هناك ضوء اخضر ولكن
هناك تحذيرات اليوم امريكيه بانه قد يكون
شيء ما همم يعني بعد منتصف الليل او خلال
منتصف الليل اما تصعيد من الطائرات
الحربيه التركيه التي تقوم بتدبير البناء
التحتيه اليوم بشكل اساسي وليست محطه
بل هناك تفضليه
حول المناطق التي يمكن ان تكون مرشحه
لتحصل فيها العمليات هناك الرفعه منبج عين
العرب وغيرها وودا اسالك عن همم اتفاقيه
يعني كم سيكون لها اهميه بتقسيم تلك
المناطق
حافظ الاسد والحكومه التركيه بشار الاسد
باركها عندما انقذه ااه اردوغان بعد عمليه
قتل الشهيد رفيق الحريري لذلك اطول
اردوغان لا يهتم لا باتفاقيه اذنه غير
اتفاقيه اردوغان يستريح الاراضي السوريه
ويقوم بعمليه التدريب في عفرين عمليه
تكريم في مناطق محتله من قبل تركيا لذلك
النظام السوري هو يريد يعني ان يتحاور مع
اردوغان لان عدوه وهو مشترك وهم ليس وحدات
الشعر بل القرد من ابناء الشعب السوري
عندما يدمر اردوغان اليوم على سبيل المثال
محطات النفط والكهرباء ما الغايه من ذلك
الغايه من ذلك عباره عن يعني الضغط على
ابناء المنطقه
المجهول كي ينفذ عوده النظام اذا تلك
المنطقه وانا قلتها قبل ايام عبر شاشاتهم
بانها ال- اا تركيا وروسيا وايران
لاعاده النظام الى مناطق شرق الفراق وقبل
بان هناك معلومات
بان ايران تخترق منطقه شرق الفرات بشكل
كبير جدا ولديها عملاء داخل قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه شكرا جزيلا لك اذن او يعني
يتبقى لدينا وقت
ايه بالنسبه لقصد هل علقت عملياتها
مع التحاليل الدولي تحديدا
القوات التركيه لانه استمرار
عدم الانشرار وعدم يعني اذا قتال القوات
التركيه والانتقاء سوف يعني انتهاء تلك
المنطقه وعودتها الى النظام السوري واح
تلها اليوم كان هناك قسط على محيط سجون
ومحيط مخيم يتواجد فيه عوائل وعناصر تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه
عبد الرحمن مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان
وينضم الينا حول هذا الموضوع من اربيل
المحلل السياسي الكردي حسين عمر اهلا بك
سيد حسين يعني اذا حصل هذا الاشتياح البري
التركي كما هدد اردوغان كيف سيكون شكله ما
همم همم ما حجمه وهل يستطيع فعليا الاكراد
همم الموجودين في الشمال السوري صده
مساء الخير لك سيدتي والاستاد المشاهدين
في الحقيقه تركيا حكومه اردوغان تعتقد ان
الظروف مناسبه اكثر من اي وقت للتحرك
للدار قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ومناطقها
وذلك لعاملين اساسيين اولا تزايد اهميه
الدور التركي بالنسبه لامريكا من جهه
ولروسيا من جهه اخرى بسبب الازمه في
اوكرانيا
والمستجد الجديد في المنطقه اندلاع
المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه في ايران والماء
الازرق الذي تعيشه الحكومه الايرانيه في
مواجهه
الاحتجاجات الداخليه اضعف موقف ايران امام
تركيا
لجهه همم صاد او منع او رفض ايراني لغزوه
تركي لمناطق سوريه في الشمال او في شمال
شرق سوريا هذا ال- ال- الامر يتوقف اذا
قبل كل شيء اذا قرر تركيا ان تشن عمليه
عسكريه بريه وهي تعلن صراحه وهذه الاطماع
موجوده وقديمه وليست جديده ف- فقط الظروف
هذا يتوقف على الموقف الدولي وخاصه الموقف
الروسي
والامريكي من الاعتداء التركي لمستمر منذ
فجر 20 همم من الشهر الجاري ولغايه الان
وتطور هذا الاعتداء بشكل
خطير جدا بشكل خطير جدا اليوم حيث تم
استهداف حاميه همم
مخيم الهول وهناك حديث عن قرار افراد من
اسر همم داعش وهناك تصريح ليوم ليس عندكم
يوم القياده المركزيه الامريكيه بين جماعه
التركيه شكلت خطرا على القوات الامريكيه
وايضا هناك استهداف في هذه اللحظات لمدينه
القامشلي اطرافها ضمنها مستشفى تقع على
اطراف مدينه القامشلي هذا الموقف همم اذا
لم يتطور الموقف الامريكي والروسي من هذا
الموقف الخجول الى الحقيقي الرابع لتركيا
تركيا ستفكر جنديا
باشتياح بري
لمناطق جديده في شمال سوريا
اخضر امريكي وايضا روسي على هذه العمليه
البريه فما حدودها خاصه بان هناك مناطق
تعتبر مزعجه بالنسبه لتركيا الرفعه مثلا
فيها قوات روسيه ومن للشيات ايرانيه
مشتركه عين العرب فيها قوات امريكيه
بريطانيه وفرنسيه يعني كيف ستحيد نفسها
تركيا عن ال- اا ربما عن الخطا عن طريق
الخطا او الاشتباك مع هذه القوات
اولا للتصحيح كوباني كوباني ليس فيها اي
وجود لقوات امريكيه او بريطانيه او فرنسيه
هناك وجود للقوات الروسيه فقط بعد غزوه
2019 خرجت القوات الامريكيه من محيط
كوباني من كوباني ومحيطها حتى في جنوب
مدينه كوباني القاعده الامريكيه الشهيره
عندما عمل الاسمنت انسحبت ليست هناك قوات
لا امريكيه ولا بريطانيا فرنسا
الدولي هناك قوات روسيه وهناك قوات النظام
السوري
ايرانيه في الركعه ولذلك انا اشرت لعامل
ايران لان ايران كانت معترضه في ربيعه
2022 حينما اعلنت تركيا عن رغبتها في
القيام بعمل عسكري في رفعت كان الموقف
الاقوى في مواجهتها والموقف الايراني
قالت لتركيا علنا اذا دخلتي الى الرفعت
ستواجهنا ستتعرضين الى حرب مع ايران ونحن
لا نستطيع ان نمنع ذلك الان هذا المعطى
تغير اذا جرت هذه العمليه البريه التركيه
هناك اولويات بالنسبه لتركيا اولا لابد من
القول ان اطماع تركيا تشمل جميع شمال
سوريا تركيا تريد ان تقيم حزام شمال سوريا
دوله شمال سوريا كما اقامت دوله شمال قبرص
المال لها هذا هو المخطط الحقيقي لتركيا
تريد ان تستولي على كامل شمال السوري وتصل
الى مناطق غرب العراق لتفتح جسرا مع غرب
العراق وصولا الى
همم تلعفر وكركوك لتحاصر اقليم كردستان
تضرب عصفورين بحجر واحد تاخذه غرب كردستان
وتحاصر الجنوب كردستان لاقلال اضعاف اهميه
اقليم كردستان واضعاف موقفه في المنطقه
امام تركيا او حتى امام الحكومه همم
العراقيه لكن اولويات تركيا تتركز الان
على رفعت يبدو ولي ومنبج بالدرجه الثانيه
ويبقى الهاجس الاكبر لاردوغان ولحزب
العداله همم كوباني التي وقفت كشوكه في
وجه داعش وكسرت اسطوره داعش وايضا هي تعزل
بين تفصل بين مناطق الاحتلال تركي في شرق
الفرات اي منطقه راس العين الابيض من جهه
ومناطق غرب الفرات بدءا من جرابلس وصولا
همم الى همم ادلب وشمال اللاذقيه اريد ان
تركز على هذه النقاط الثلاثه في البدايه
لكن مشروعها الاحتلال وهذه الحرب
العدوانيه تستهدف الى احتلال كامل شمال
سوريا واقامه منطقه تركيه ليست عربيه لا
تجري عمليات تعريف في شمال سوريا تجري
عمليات تدريب هناك 14% من سكان سوريا
موجودين داخل تركيا الان يتم تتركهم بشكل
14% من سكان سوريا في مناطق الاحتلال
التركي ايضا تتم عمليه تجميد بشكل مباشر
28% من سكان سوريا تتعرض لعمليه هاتريك
مهجاه في سبيل مشروع احتلال تركي في سوريا
اذا المحلل السياسي من اربيل حسين عمر
شكرا جزيلا لك
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
شركه تكنولوجيا تايوانيه توقف التعامل مع
ايران بسبب استخدام التقنياتها في تصنيع
الاسلحه
[موسيقى]
مستشفى المواساه بالخبر اول مستشفى في
القطاع الخاص يقدم خدمه استبدال مفصل
الركبه باستخدام الروبوت الجراحي من خلال
الاستفاده من خدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي رحله
علاج اقصر واسهل المواساه خبره تنبض
بالثقه عائله الرئيس كانت تتدخل في الايام
الاخيره في القرارات ليله
المجال الامن
موضوع القناصه فيما بعد تبين انهم جاءوا
من الخارج
الوزيره الفرنسيه
لو كنتم كان رئيس الجمهوريه لا اغير على
راسه وزاره الداخليه في خدم
الاخبار لا تتوقف ابدا الناس تحصل عليها
من عده مصادر
من وسائل مختلفه طوال الوقت
[موسيقى]
منها ما هو مهم وما هو اهمك
ويستدعي ان نصلي الضوء عليه لمناقشه
تضعه في عدسه واحده
لابعد الحدود
[موسيقى]
الثامنه على شاشه العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد تحولت شوارع المدن
الكرديه في ايران الى صحه حرب بعد ارسال
السلطات الايرانيه قوات حربيه وتعرض
الاهالي لحمله قمع في وقت تتواصل فيه
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في
ومهابات وسننتج غيرها من المدن ايضا في
اطار التظاهرات التي لم تهدا منذ شهرين
[موسيقى]
اهلين
تقارير حقوقيه اشارت الى منع النظام
الايراني ايصال الدم الى المستشفيات في
مدينتي شهر وتضامنا مع المدن الكرديه غربي
ايران دعت مجموعه تطلق على نفسها الشباب
الثوار في ايران الى اغلاق المحلات
والاعمال التجاريه يوم غد في عمومي اراده
كما طلب مركز تعاون الاحزاب الكرديه في
ايران المنظمات السياسيه والنشاطاء
المدنيين وكافه فئات الشعب الايراني
بتنظيم اضراب عام يوم غد ايضا من اجل
تعزيز الوحده والتضامنه ودعم الشعب الكردي
بالتزامن دار السينما الايرانيه رفعت
الصوت عاليه واكدت انه في حال عدم انتهاء
التهديدات والاعتقالات والاستدعاءات
المتتاليه لاعضائها وعدم الافراج عن
السينمائيين الموقفين فانها ستطلب من
اعضاءها الاعتصام والانتناء عن التعاون مع
المشاريع السينمائيه والتلفزيونيه منظمه
حقوق الانسان في ايران التي تتخذ من اصله
مقر كشفت في تقريرها عن مقتل 416 شخصا على
يد القوات الامنيه ممن فيهم 51 طفلا و21
امراه ورفضت الى ان 72 شخصا لقوا حتفهم
الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بك سيد حسن تركيز همم السلطات
الايرانيه على قمع المناطق الكرديه والان
يعني ارسلت قوات حربيه
على ماذا يدل هل يدل على انه يمكن يريدون
ان يظهروا كل او يسحب كل اسلحتهم لي قمع
هذه الاحتجاجات واذكاتها ام انه يعني هناك
تركيز على الاكراد
والمشاهدين اعتقد انه التركيز ليس فقط على
الاكراد يعني بدا
التركيز والقمع الشديد والوحشي في
بلوشستان ثم انتقل الى اذربيجان وايضا في
ومن ثم في كردستان يعني كل مناطق الشعوب
غير الفارسيه تعرضت الى هجوم واستخدم
النظام الايراني اليات حربيه
ورشاشات الى قتل المحتاجين والمتظاهرين
هذا يحس يعني الخوف المضاعف من الشعوب غير
الفارسيه لانه بالاضافه الى مطالبها في
اسقاط النظام الايراني ايضا لديها مطالب
قوميه وهذا ما يخيف النظام ايراني واي
سلطه مركزيه هذه المطالب القوميه التي لا
يريدها النظام الايراني ولا تريدها اي
نظام مركزي ان تظهر وخوف الاكراد في هذه
الخوف من الاكراد في هذه الايام همم لانه
الاكراد ايضا المشتعل ثوره فيها يعني في
هذه الايام بشكل كبير وايضا لا يريدون ان
يتطبق النموذج الكردي اي همم يعني همم حكم
ذاتي او فيدراليه في كردستان العراق لا
يتطبق ولا تتكرر تجربه في كردستان ايران
لذلك ايران ليس اا لا تقمع اقراض ايران
فقط بل اتجهت بصوارخها وايضا مسيراتها اذا
كنت تستان العراق للقضاء على اي قوه كرديه
ناعمه او همم او او تحضن همم يعني همم
اللاجئين الاكراد الذين يهربون من البطش
الايران لذلك هذا البطش وهذا القمع هو
متوجه بشكل مضاعف اتجاه الشعوب غير
الفارسيه التي تطالب بحقوقها القوميه
حسن يعني هناك حديث لافت اليوم للرئيس همم
رئيس رئيس الايرانيه يقول بانه النظام
مستعد للحوار مع المحتجين ولكنه بنفس
الوقت وصفهم بمثابه
الذين يلجاون الى العنف فعليا النظام
الايراني الان جاهز ويريد حقا ان يتحاور
مع المحتاجين وهل فعلا رئيسي اصلا هو من
بيده قرار التفاوض او لا
اعتقد ابراهيم رئيسي ليس بيده بيده قرار
التفاوض لانه الكنمل الاولى والاخيره هي
بيد خاميه وايضا خامني يعني ابراهيم رئيس
هو موظف لا اكثر بيده خاميه لا يستطيع اي
قرار دون المراجعه بل بدون تعليمات خامنه
لذلك طبعا كل الدعوات التي نسمعها من هنا
وهناك هي من اجل تخدير الشارع والتقدير
الشعوب وتفويت الفرصه عليهم لذلك انا
اعتقد انه في هذه الفرصه النظام الايراني
يعني استخدمت تكتيك واستراتيجيه واحده بعد
ما فشلت كل محاولاته الاحتواء على الثوره
وهي القمع المفرط راينا يعني النداءات من
خامنه وايضا همم تكررت على لسان الكثير من
المسؤولين بانه القمع والاعدامات والطريق
الاوحد الذي لابد وان يعني يتعاملون همم
مع المحتاجين به انا اعتقد انه ابراهيم
رئيس لا يستطيع اتخاذ اي قرار ولا يستطيع
ان يعني تجاوب مع مطالب المحتجين شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا من لندن الباحث في الشان
الايراني حسن
[موسيقى]
راديو
اوقفت شركه تكنولوجيه تايوانيه اعمالها مع
ايران وسط تحقيق فيما اذا كانت قد انتهت
العقوبات الدوليه حيث تكثف الولايات
المتحده تدقيقها في انتاج ايران العسكري
وتورطها في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وبحسب تقرير دهيله الامريكيه اوقفت شركه
ايتن انترناشونال قبول الطلبات من ايران
ومنع التصديرها منتجاتها الى البلاد بعد
المخاوف التي اثرتها منظمه متحدون ضد
ايران النوويه وتشير مخاوف المنظمه
واستجابه لشركه ايتن الى مشكله اكبر حيث
يبدو ان ايران تبحث عن المواد اللازمه
لبرنامج الطائرات بدون طيار على الرغم
الجهود التي تبذلها الولايات المتحده
واوروبا لعزل النظام بالعقوبه كما تشمل
المخاوف من ان منتجات ايتن يتم شراءها من
قبل شركات تكنولوجيا المعلومات الايرانيه
رايموند كمبيوترز والتي يبدو انها تتاجر
مع الحرس الثوري الاسلامي الايراني مما
وضع الشركه امام انتهاكات محتمله للعقبات
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
قالت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان ثلث المعلنين
الكبار في منصه تويتر اوقفوا اعلاناتهم
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين وذكرت انه لم
يواصل الاعلان على تويتر اكثر من ثلث اكبر
مئه مسوق في الاسبوعين الماضيين وفقا
تحليل لصحيفه او لهذه الصحيفه لبيانات
التصوير وهو مؤشر على مدى التقلب بين
المعلمين بعد سيطره الملياردير ماسك على
الشركه
[موسيقى]
اذا مئه معلن واكثر بينهم افضل 14 معلن
واكبرهم توقف او امتنعوا انصحى التعبير عن
الاعلامي فتوه خلال الاسابيع الفائته
والتي وصفت بالفتره الفوضويه التي سيطر
فيها الى الماسك على المنصه الزرقاء وبهرت
بيانات ماتكس وهي شركه تحليل بيانات
التسويق الرقمي اظهرت ان شركه الادويه
مارك وشركه كالوجز لصناعه الحبوب وشركه
فيرسون همم وشركه باستن بير قد اوقفت ايضا
اعلاناتها على تويتر في الاسابيع الاخيره
ثم اتت الضربه الكبيره من مجموعه امني كام
لدعايته والتسويق التي اصدرت في الثانيه
عشر من نوفمبر الجاري توصيه لعملائها بوقف
انفاقهم مؤقتا على الاعلانات في تويتر على
المدى القصير درمت ضربه فعليا قام اعتبرت
موجع لانها تخدم وتعلن عن اكثر من 5000
عميل في 70 دوله من بينهم مقدونلدز وابل
وجونسن وتؤكد هذه الخطوه حقوقا متزايده
بين الوكالات والعلامات التجاريه حول
مستقبل موقع تويتر منذ استحواذ الين ماسك
عليه مقابل 44 مليار دولار
وتظهر هذه التوترات ان قدره التويتر على
الحفاظ على المستوى السابق لاجراءات سلامه
العلامه التجاريه وفعاليتها قد تكون معوقه
على المدى القريب والادفاع عن نفسه
وسياسته ماسك باللوم على مجموعات الحقوق
المدنيه في انخفاض الارادات بشكل كبير مع
ضغطها على معلنتر لمقاطعه الخدمه الى ان
يوضح ماسك كيف سيتحكم في المعلومات
المضلله وخطاب الكراهيه على تويتر وهو ما
لم يتوضح بشكل نهائي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مستمره فيها
اكثر من 200 اطلاق نار
[موسيقى]
تتمتع دول الخليج بقيمه عالميه كبيره
لليوم رخاء وتطور وضعها على خريطه الدول
الاولى
لكن المنطقه التي نعيش فيها مليئه
بالسراحات تهديدات اقليميه من دول اخرى
منظمات ارهابيه وجماعات المسلحه كيف يمكن
مواجهه هذه الاخطاء ومتابعه النمو في ان
واحد
ستواجهها الدول وهذه المجتمعات هل يمكن
المضيء قدما في
مصريه وبنائي ذهنيه حاضنه للتنميه في كل
مجالاتها اهم الموضوعات المتعلقه بشان
الخليجي مع ابرز المحللين والمختصرين
[موسيقى]
يحاول صحبه زله من المعنيين ارتيادها هذا
الطريق الصعب ان توافق ابشري الديدي السبت
الثالثه والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اربط هو الاحزمه واسترخو هذه رحله الى
عالم اخر سنمزج فيه الافتراضي والمؤسس
كلمات معقده صحيح دعيني اوفر عليك الوقت
تعالوا معي
سريعا ومختلف جدا والمهم
نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره الكامله
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لا هجمات روسيه
بالمسيرات على اوكرانيا منذ 17 من نوفمبر
الجاري هذا ما كشفت عنه الاستخبارات
البريطانيه مضيفه انه من المحتمل نفاذ
مخزون روسيا من الطائرات المسيره ايرانيه
الصنع وستسعى على الارجح للحصول على
المزيد خلال الفتره المقبله وفيما بدا
كانه تبادل الادوار اتخذ الجيش الاوكراني
هذه المره وضعيه المهاجم بالمسيرات واين
على شبه جزيره القرم التي اعلن حاكمها
الروسي اسقاط عده مسيرات اوكرانيا وفي وقت
يتوقع فيه يتوقع ان يكون الشتاء او قاسيا
على اوكرانيا اعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه
عن ان مئات المستشفيات ومشات الرعايه
الصحيه في اوكرانيا تفتقر الى الوقود
والماء والكهرباء لتلبيه الاحتياجات
الاساسيه للافراد
[موسيقى]
عشره
اطلاق نار في سوبر
ماركتنا الامريكي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا لا يكاد يمر شهر الا و تشهد فيه
ولايات امريكيه حوادث اطلاق نار يذهب
ضحيتها عشرات الابرياء بينهم اطفال وفي كل
مره تحي هذه الحوادث الجدل المحتدم
بالبلاد حول الاستخدام وشراء العشوائي
للاسلحه الناريه ولعل ابرز اهداف حالات
اطلاق النار هي المدارس واحدا اشهر
حوادثها هي اطلاق النار في امريكا مقتل 26
شخصا بينهم 20 طفلا من طلبه الابتدائيه في
ولايه كوناكري عام 2012 بعد ما فتح رجل
النار عليهم في مدرسه ساندي هوك ايضا في
العام
يعني يتعشر قتل طالب في مدرسه ثانويه
بولايه التاكساس 8 من زملائه وهي الحادثه
التي سبقتها بعده اشهر حادثه اخرى رحبتها
17 شخصا ويمكر اطلاق النار في مدرسه
ابتدائيه في اوفالدي بولايه تكساس فيمايو
هذا العام والذي اسفر عن مقتل 18 طفلا
وثلاثه بالغين الحادث رقم 27 في المدارس
الامريكيه هذا العام لوحده وفقا لمنظمه
متخصصه بتعقب هذه الحوادث كذلك السوبر
ماركت والمتاجر الكبيره والمتوسطه تعد
هدفا لمطلق النار ايضا حيث شهدت بوفالو
بنيويورك حديثا ايضا فيما الماضي اطلاق
نار او ده بحياه 10 اشخاص وشهدت امريكا
منذ بدايه العام الحالي اكثر من 200 حادث
اطلاق نار اسفرت عن مقتل اكثر من 250 شخصا
وانا هات الولايات المتحده عام 2001 2020
ب 693 عمليه اطلاق جماعي وفقا لقرشيف
العنف المسلح فيما شهد العام
2020 نحو 611 حادثا وشاهد عام 2019 وهو
الاخر
417 حادثا
[موسيقى]
وتنضم الينا من واشنطن مراسله العربيه
ناديه البلبيسي اهلا بك ناديه يعني قبل
الدخول بتفاصيل هذه الظاهره التي لا تتوقف
ويروح ضحيتها الاطفال شهريا تقريبا هل من
معلومات جديده حول حادثه اطلاق النار التي
حصلت في السوبر ماركت همم
الاخيره يعني هل عرف من هو المنفذ لانه
الشرطه اكدت انه قتل
بالفعل طبعا الحادثه التي جرت في ورمات
وهو مركز تجاري معروف لديه افرع في
الولايات المتحده يقال بانه هذا الشخص هو
كان ااا مسؤول في احد الاقسام في المتجر
ولديه بعض المشاكل مع الموظفين قام بفتح
النار وقتل خمس اشخاص تقريبا همم حتى الان
انا في اذا هو قتل نفسه او انه الشرطه
عندما تم الاتصال طبعا الخط المعروف بانها
اتت واا تم الاشتباك معه وتم قتله لكن على
كل الاحوال كل هذه الاحصائيات التي تحدثت
عنها راويه تشير مره اخرى الى كل هذه
الحوادث التي تجري في الولايات المتحده
على غرار باقي دول العالم لا نسمع بها الا
هنا واصبحت في الواقعه امر عادي يعني
للاسف رغم ان هناك دوما احتجاجات في داخل
المؤسسات الحكوميه هناك مطال من البيت
الابيض بتقنين استخدام السلاح لكن في كل
مذبحه يكون هناك وقفه همم لكل المسؤولين
ويكون هناك غضب شعبي لكن لا شيء يحدث في
النهايه لانه كما تعرفين اللوبي المؤيد
اللي بايع السلاح يعتبر من اقوى اللوبيات
في الولايات المتحده لاحدا يستطيع تحدي
ولحد حتى الان سهوله الحصول على السلاح
سهله ومن هناك تاتي كل هذه عمليه اطلاق
النار وكل هذه الحوادث ما هي الولايات
ناديه التي تسمح او تسهل حيازه همم
الاسلحه الفرديه
كل الولايات تقريبا باستثناء العاصمه
واشنطن لانها مقاطعه لكن بشكل عام كل
الولايات تسمح باستخدام السلاح حاليا قبل
تقريبا اسبوعين نيويورك حاولت منع استخدام
السلاح في مناطق معينه مثل تايم سكوير
وغيرها لكن بشكل عام تقريبا كل الولايات
ااه وبالتالي من هنا يعني اذا نظرنا الى
كل هذه الحوادث التي تحدثت عنها باسهاب
سواء كان اطلاق نار في مدرسه او ما رايناه
في الاسبوع الماضي فقط كان هناك في
فرجينيا بالتحديد اطلاق نار في متجر
واطلاق نار في جامعه وهي جامعه مشهوره
جامعه فرجينيا
وكان هناك ايضا اطلاق نار في كلورادو همم
في همم في نادي ليلي وبالتالي يعني لا
يوجد مكان معين نقول بانه يتم استهداف هذا
المكان لاسباب معينه على العكس يعني
هيا الحوادث هي مرتبطه فقط بسهوله الحصول
على السلاح سواء كان الهجوم على مدرسه او
كان في نادي او كان في سينما او كان في
متجر يعني الحوادث تتكرر احيانا تكون
اعتباطيه ومعظم الاشخاص الذين يقومون
باستخدام السلاح او بشراء هذا السلاح اما
لديهم سجل باقتراب نفسي او لديهم مشاكل
عائليه او حتى سجل اجرامي الى غيره لكن
حتى الان البيت الابيض يحاول منذ فتره منذ
ساندي هوك المذبح التي تحدثت عنها همم في
قناتك في عهد الرئيس اوباما الذي كان يبكي
حتى عندما كان يتحدث مع اهل الطلاب الذين
قتلوا لم يستطيع احد ان يفعل شيئا هناك
بعض الاجراءات في الكونجرس لكن هناك تعطيل
من قبل بعض الجمهوريين الذين على فكره هذا
اللوبي هو الذي يمول الحملات الانتخابيه
وبالتالي هناك ارتباط عضوي ما بين همم
دعوه الى عدم تقييد استخدام السلاح من قبل
الانروا وهو لوبيا السلعه وبين اعضاء
الكونجرس الذين يتلقون دعما ماديا منه حتى
الان لا احد يتجرا على بتر هذه العلاقه
لكن طبعا في كل مره نرى فيها مذبحه خصوصا
الاخيره في تكساس وعندما يكون الوضع متعلق
بتلاميذ او طلاب صغار في المدرسه نسمع
دعوات جديده الى تقليل استخدام السلاح
شكرا جزيلا لك ناديه قلب البيسي مراسله
العربيه
دلعت احتجاجاتهم عنيفه في اكبر مصنع
لهواتف ايفون من انتاج ابل في مدينه تشنج
شو الصينيه حيث خرج مئات العمال بشكل
جماعي احتجاجا على العقود المخادعه من قبل
الشركه والتعرض المحتمل لفايروس
[تصفيق]
نهايه النشره تذكرهم بالعناصر
[موسيقى]
الاسيويه في المونديال العربيه تستطلع
وراء الجماهير وتوقعاتهم للمنتخب الفائز
فرنسا
ايش هذا مرسيدس
الكرديه شمال سوريا وتقصف منشاه للغاز في
الحسكه
النظام الايراني يرسل قوات حربيه لقمع
الاحتجاجات في المدن الكرديه ودعوات
لاضراب عام لمواجهته القمر
بعد هجره المهندسين تويتر تواجه هجره
المعلنين وماسك يحملوا جماعه الحقوق
المدنيه مسؤوليه الخسائر